welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the Mandalorian season 3
episode 6 directed by Bryce Dallas
Howard this is her doing her third
Mandalorian episode after she also sat
in the chair for chapter 4 and chapter
11. Bryce always brings something big
with her and her father of course also
directed solo making this family almost
as important as the Skywalkers are Bryce
directed the first appearance of bow two
and she's very much bringing things full
circle from that initial entry titled
the RS so now seeing Bo grow into a
lineage and it's making for a great
character Arc after this week we have
just two entries remaining with us
getting the penultimate episode next
time before the finale that comes the
Wednesday after there's a lot of things
going down and in this video we're going
to be going through the Easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed
along with art theories make sure you
smash the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy
the video and please hit the Subscribe
button so you don't miss us like a
stormtrooper without the way cause I
always miss don't they now the way
thanks for clicking the video now let's
get another Mandalorian now last week's
on Navarro being overrun by Captain
gorion's forces desperate for help grief
cargo reached out to the new Republic
which we saw was slowly being overrun by
the amount of bureaucracy that they now
had to handle the other Rebels did a
great job of taking down the Empire
great job the resistance simply didn't
have the means to actually run a
government without the Jedi's help and
thus the first daughter started to rise
up in the fractures Captain tiva ended
up going to the mandalorians for help
and we watched as they returned home to
the planet Navarro this is where we
first met them in season one and after
beating gorion they were given a piece
of land that they could finally call
home the armor had a quiet word with bow
Katan and she said that she actually
believed that she'd seen a myth saw and
that she was the chosen one who could
unite the mandalorians they're people
that have been racked with civil wars
for centuries and I generally think that
the Civil Wars gotten out of hand
anyway Beau removed her helmet to show
that this is the way enhance space we
saw as tiva discovered that the rumors
of moff Gideon's death had been greatly
exaggerated I've seen a lot of theories
online saying that this is where Kara
June was killed and that would give in
any universal reason for why she's no
longer in the show I'm not sure how much
I dig that but I don't really think
Disney are going to go back and hire her
so who knows if this will be revealed to
be her fate at some point gonna be
kickoffs either way so we're moving on
and get an episode soon
now we start off in space and see a
giant ship designed to look almost like
a shellfish this is quite fitting too as
it contains quarans on it which are
aquatic life forms from the planet
monkala alongside the calamari they'd
had Civil Wars for centuries and whereas
they formed off into their own more
peaceful species the Quran always tend
to be the bad guys now we discover that
this group have a bounty on their head
because of a mon calamari who's angry
that Captain shugarth was shugging her
son we discovered that the quarans
finally have peace with their Rivals and
this is very much a Romeo and Juliet
story in which two people from opposing
sides have fallen in love I love how the
captains in a water tank and you can
even see her see inside of it when she's
flowing around now discover early on
that they're returning to Trask and this
is the same location that Mando met boa
during the RS episode Imperials
seemingly arrive and the first clue that
this might not be what it seems is that
this is actually moth Gideon's class 546
like Cruiser we then get the return of
several characters from the RS episode
including ax wolves and Costco Reeve
they demand the guy back and we get a
kind of kind of goofy Doctor Who opening
to the entry that also goes a bit goofy
I'll be honest either way they take him
in and we cut the guns to higher title
before we get bow and Co venturing out
on her Gauntlet to plazier 15. plasier
means pleasure which this entire Place
really is and everyone's just chilling
out maxing and relaxing and Jack
Blackson and axing but I'm not a rapper
traveling to a platform we see here all
group as they go in and discover that
they've been lying alone an independent
planet to me this planet very much
represents the vision of what Mandalore
could look like and it's basically one
of those Society if heavy spoilers
didn't exist memes there's a giant Dom
in the middle much like the sundari and
also monorail as well as some ebony
droids this denotes that they're
Imperial and it's clear that the planet
is very much using the older aspects of
their Arsenal to build something better
this is why they have Star Destroyers
and droids like this greeting people to
arrive the protocol Droid we meters ra7
and these gain the nickname insect
droids due to their facial features used
heavily on the Death Star they've often
appeared throughout the Saga and this is
normally to denote Imperial superiority
you also see later on that the guards
with Jack Black are wearing Stormtrooper
uniforms hammering home this idea that
it's good to recycle now inside the
monorail car they have to show their
chain codes and these are basically just
a form of ID we hear there's been new
chorus and Accords passed through the
Galaxy and this means that people have
to identify themselves before going into
peacekeeping zones it's very much like
what the Imperials used to do when
they'd force people to show their papers
you know what that's a reference to and
it also shows the useless bureaucracy
that the Republic of enforced in the
Galaxy they're more worried about stuff
like this than pirates in the first
order and this is why their vision of
the Galaxy ended up failing now why Bo
such an important character to put at
the Forefront is because she's very much
walked the line between the two sides
Belle comes from the royal family of
Mandalore Birch is also been
impoverished she's been a part of the
death watch switched sides when Darth
Maul took over led the night owls and
also her own smaller sect she's now also
been part of the children of the watch
and has walked among them too boa's seen
firsthand her sister city and stance of
pacifism and she's also held the dark
saber as well Bo is very much your ideal
candidate for leadership because she's
seen almost every Walk of Life and she
understands how every Creed works I
don't want to get crazy crazy political
mate but will say that I tend to trust
leaders who've actually lived the life
of the people that they're judging and
not the Super Rich Mega Lords who don't
know how to fill up a car at a petrol
station so I think that Bo really works
well as the leader but unfortunately
she's dealing with mandalorians
unfortunately it's in their nature to
fight one another and this is because of
their Warrior Lifestyle the reason
people stop following her in the first
place was because she didn't get the
darksabra in combat and there she was
seen as a false Leader by many
mandalorian's demand a strong leader up
at the front of them and this ties all
the way back to Mandalore the gray 8 who
pretty much set the path that they now
follow this idea of a Mandalorian leader
having walked several ways of life is
also something that we've seen in top
Isla at one point the mandalorians and
Jedis were enemies but Toros up as a
Jedi Mandalorian and he United the two
sides he was the one who created the
darksaber that brought everyone together
and this was due to him knowing both a
Jedi and also the mandalorians thus Beau
could do the same thing and her being
selected as leader is very important as
long as Mando plays along too which I
think he will we are gonna see a very
strong leader in her possibly we will
see how that goes but unfortunately I
also think they haven't stopped the
divisions that could end up Rising once
more in the future see you champ now
they arrive to find a big banquet led by
Jack Black and lizzo kinda jumped the
shark a bit here mate didn't you and
yeah I'll guess we'll see what the
internet reaction to this is now at the
table we can catch lots of different
species including an i thorian some
celestes and the same species as the
Frog lady who again RS episode Jack
Black wants to address the panther in
the room and that is why the is
Jack Black and lizzo in Star Wars
sorry losing myself a bit there anyway
the banter in the room is of course a
play on the phrase elephant in the room
and Panthers themselves were based on
mammoths which were the precursors to
elephants now turns out that he was an
imperial during the war but we see that
the amnesty program has accepted him
back you might notice that he has an
amnesty lapel on his top and huge shout
outs to ryanairy for pointing out that
this is actually an A in arabesh now we
didn't mention this last week but Ryan
are we bloody Roy you know he's pointing
out that Carson and Zeb could be members
of blue Squadron this group have
featured at several points in The Saga
including the Battle of Endor and many
of the dogfights we've seen now just to
clear up another thing from last week we
pointed out the rancor patch on teva's
uniform which we've now had cleared up
Paul Sun hung Lee plays the character
and it was revealed that he actually
helped design his character's costume
originally his bomber jacket had several
different custom patches on it and these
were all designed by the actor the
rancor was originally supposed to be a
bulldog but in order to make it more in
line with Star Wars they changed to the
Beast they also originally thought of
doing a Rancor claw instead but they
settled on the head in the end anyway
back to Jack Black and he's helped to
rebuild the planet showing what the
amnesty program has done again this
entire planet's repurposing things from
the Imperials and every aspect ever
carries over something from what's come
before as an ex-imperial oh he's not
allowed to create his own Army unless
he's had to hide the mandalorians to
protect over the planet now you might
notice that when lizzo is sitting down
that there's this big hologram flower
thing and we see this trolling behind
her as she walks along later on we learn
that Jack Black got in with her because
she was one of the royal family and they
fell in love and started holding
Democratic elections this led to them
still being in charge but they're very
pompous and yeah what the f what the
they're doing in Star Wars elizo's
character is called The Duchess and Bo's
sister satin was one of these as well
they are very much pacifists too and
they don't allow blasters to be brought
into the city Jack Black's characters
called Bombardier and this typically
refers to either a member of a bombing
crew or a non-commissioned officer put
in charge of artillery now it turns out
that they have a bit of a problem and
some of the droids have ended up
malfunctioning they've tried to reform
our battle droids but now they've risen
up and balmander have been picked to
take them down now from here we go to
Christopher Lloyd who's in our third big
Cameo of the entry always nice seeing
this guy back and he talks about how the
droids were saved from being scrapped on
carthon and this is actually a prison
Moon and it contained the carth and chop
fuels which is where droids were
destroyed and also dismantled you could
call it the carthon warehouse but the
reason the droids are rebelling is
revealed to us later on they're very
much used as slaves and no they don't
say this specifically there are a lot of
nods to Blade Runner in this episode
which I'll be talking about later on in
that the replicants were sick of being
used having these short life spans and
this is very much the case with the
droids as well they get their minds
wiped over and over and over and don't
really get free will as they're
constantly swapping sides we see the
Havoc they've Unleashed then you can
also catch an m68 land speeder that's
being crashed this is the same model as
the one hand had at the start of solo
and we learned that it's a widespread
problem a cool Droid or CEO Droid also
goes berserk as well and it spins its
knives around similar what one did in
the book of Boba Fett might be reaching
here but it looks like one of the
customers is wearing the carpet from The
Shining and with this being a bar scene
it might be a reference of that might
not be but but I see The Shining carpet
everywhere these days and I just can't
avoid it mentally now they can't shut
them off because people are so reliant
on Droids now that they've become
useless it's very much us seeing the
future of humanity before we're all
wiped out by Rogue AI yay chatbot can
make my job completely useless now the
then directed it ignores and this is the
same species as queel they also appeared
as one of the Pirates and gordian's ship
and this one was dressed like Smee from
Peter Pan Masters when it comes to
droids they first showed up in the Saga
on Cloud City and were the reason that
C3PO got dismantled in the room he can
catch Super Battle Droids as well and
building off the back of the bad batch
is very much the idea that the
separatists were actually the good guys
in a way now the ergonauts ignore all
forms of royalty and titles and it's not
until Mando steps forward and says that
he knows quill that they look up using
their catchphrase I have spoken against
her attention and I'm sure they reused
some of the queel masks and just bangs
sideburns on them I know it was you now
they deny that they're the reason the
droids are malfunctioning and because
Mando treats him with the respect he had
for queel they give him a way to track
the Rogues at the loading dock we see
more Super Battle Droids and there's
definitely this feeling of unease
throughout this scene and the main
reason Mano didn't destroys in the first
place was because when he was younger
they of course attacked his home this
feeling was felt by many people
throughout the Galaxy as droids were of
course used for oppression during the
Clone Wars this is why droids were
banned from the most Eisley Cantina and
it took people a long time to get over
the fact that they were used to disrupt
most people's way of life they go to the
Head battle droid four men and Manos
starts to try and tick them off to see
if they react eventually he fishes one
out and again we get a sort of Riff on
Blade Runner with Mano chasing his
Target through a crowded Street blade
runner's on my mind a lot as we've just
finished a big breakdown of it which
will be dropping on the channel on
Saturday if you're not a member if you
are a member then it's out now and if
you want to support the channel just
click the join button below just costs
99 Cents you'll get to see that video
early which it is it's worth it I
promise thanks now eventually they take
the Droid down with a crime scene being
created by some Constable droids instead
of yellow tape we get a hologram
shooting up I love when Star Wars
transforms things from real life again
it's similar to zoro's death in Blade
Runner and Bones of discovering a spark
pad on it leading them to a Droid bar
called the resistor it's a nice little
punny play on words now a resistor is a
device that restricts the flow of a
current and to resist of course means to
rise up in the streets you might also
notice that there's a lot of droids and
this shows how integrated into this
society that they are inside the bar we
see an Ric 920 and this is what carried
Anakin and Padme about on Tatooine we
also catch a white Droid and this is a
cz1 model which first appeared in A New
Hope you then can see an rx24 as Bowen
Manda walk in and these were first
introduced in Galaxy's Edge I love the
record skip moment and it kind of
reminded me a lot of the opening of
American Werewolf in London or any time
that I've walked into a non-spoiler
review bar Mando and bow do the whole
good cop bad cop routine using fear to
try and get answers the droids possess
here too when they were that if the
uprisings continue that they're gonna be
wiped out either how unwieldy they are
droids make a good Workforce because
they obey but the second that they stop
doing that then it's gonna be curtains
for them we get more shots at the bar
and can also catch a Droid holding us a
back card which is basically the Star
Wars equivalent of Poker there's also an
evroid as well which was used as Jabba's
torture Droid the pain so mad as being
sympathetic and even though a lot of
them were separated Imperials they just
want to be alive and have a purpose
really makes you start to see them in a
new life and it made me sort of think
are we the bad guys and the bartender
mentions nepante being served in the bar
though it's been used on machines here
the wood itself actually pulls from an
ancient potion that was used to relieve
pain sorrow grief and also suffering
this is what we program the droids and
yeah it wasn't the ignore too up
I won't have anyone being racist about
those little lug nuts you here I
have spoken this episode is very much a
sort of detective Noir story in which we
get the pair investigating what's going
on and we see the classic body slab
scene this is some it also popped up in
Blade Runner 2049 and it's a staple in
stories like this where they're almost
becoming a cliche repurpose torty
droidism brought in to drain fluid from
the recent resistor and this causes it
to end up attacking them we see Mando is
getting a bit more to grips with the
darksaber and though Beau gets it back
at the end of the episode I don't think
that's the last time that Mando will
hold it I can actually imagine him
getting it back in further episodes and
like I said before that there is sort of
this Civil War ingrained into the
mandalorians now we get another Blade
Runner 2049 nod when they start to scan
the substance in the film they looked at
Rachel's bones and zoomed in to find a
serial number denoting that she was a
replicant here though they discover a
chain code and this allows them to start
to track its origin they also do the
cliche thing with the scientists where
they brush it to the side and it's the
character that spots what's actually
going on there's also a mention of the
Techno Union and this is a group that
first appeared in an attack of the
Clones
[Music]
thank you
now turns out there's been some
underhanded dealings from commissioner
Hellgate and we discovered that he
brought them in illegally Helga might be
a play on Hell's Gate and how he could
open up everything and bring it all down
now they go back to the future ristic
control room which is where the truth is
finally revealed he holds his hand over
a big red button and this can turn them
back to being battle droids which will
wipe out the population now this is
clearly similar to order 66 and no
clones were thought to be better than
droids we saw firsthand how much they
could be programmed too in the end this
and the costs were why the Imperials
moved away from using them and we
discovered that Hellgate was in fact a
separatist getting political mate you
know we hate that on the channel and
they take him down by using his stun
blast on him cut back to the Garden
bowls now we see grago using the force
to help out the duchess Amanda and
baurai with Hellgate and he says this
calling the stiffing slimy this is not
only a play on the phrase the pot
calling kettle black but it's also an
in-universe reference to this
if that's not the quack to call in the
stifling slimy now Hellgate has clearly
lived on the planet for a while and he
sees the life that they've given to the
population has been something that's
forced it to decline algae apologized to
The Duchess and asks for her grace and
man's gonna be out no time with these
soft bloody work PC liberals that just
love letting people get away with stuff
now he's exiled to the Moon of paraquat
for the time being but my guess is that
he's gonna be back at some point Bo is
then given the key to the city and this
is handed over by a BNI Droid or bunny
if you're me Kroger is knighted too and
though this doesn't make him a Jedi
Knight it's pretty close that is
possible one day that Kroger might even
become the leader of Mandalore itself he
of course has a very long life span and
being part of the Jedi as well will
allow him to become almost like
torvisler Yoda was on the Jedi Council
for centuries and this allowed him to
have a wisdom that very few others
possessed if we think about what Manuel
was gonna look like in 100 years from
now then all of these characters will be
dead or as Grog who will still be
classed as being very young therefore
they might even end up opponing him as a
leader sometime down the line and I
think that would be such a cool
direction to take his character in
anyway they head out to the old crew and
Bo shows that she's very much got
imposter syndrome and wrestles with what
to do when they arrive everyone's just
kind of hanging out drinking tea and
playing catch but they get a frosty
reception when it comes to ax but I'm
not a rapper Beau challenges him and the
pair took it out and I kind of wish that
this was the main focus of the episode
droids worrying about being replaced by
humans is a nice play on how humans
worry about being replaced by AI but
they didn't explore to the extent that I
think it was justified spending that
much time with it I wish we had more of
a focus on the Mandalorian in fighting
like this and showed the politics even
though I hate Politics the bow wins but
ax says that no one will follow her as
long as she doesn't hold the darksaber
she gives her we are stronger together
speech and definitely shows that she
wants to unite Everyone by openly
accepting Mando he goes to give her the
darksaber again and she very much
references Sabine who too gifted her in
Rebels it has to be one in combat though
or taken another way Beyond just being
handed over from one to another however
in a technicality he talks about episode
2 and brings up how he was held hostage
she took it during that episode and
saved Mando and thus she defeated the
enemy that defeated him meaning that she
now has it she's once more moving
further up the chain and at this point
she has all the pieces in place to
become the leader of Mandalore now
interestingly I did think that we'd
learned from these exactly what happened
with moff Gideon last week his ship was
ambushed by mandalorians and when we
start off with them I assume that they'd
be revealed to be the ones behind the
attack on the shuttle he still hasn't
popped up but I do feel like him in the
amnesty act have Bloom larchy over the
season even if they've always just kind
of been in the background the amnesty
act meant that many soldiers could swap
sides and this was similar Operation
Paperclip after the second in World War
this allowed some of the Nazi scientists
to come to America and it's a similar
setup to what we had in the case of Dr
Pershing like the Nuremberg trials
though those complicit in war crimes
were sent before judges and juries in
order to decide what was going to happen
to them moth Gideon is up there some of
the worst Imperial officers in the
galaxy and though we don't know his
entire backstory there are minor things
we've been told Gideon actually made a
name for himself by working in the ISB
and this is an organization that we've
seen in and or on the bad batch through
this he was heavily complicit in the
Great Purge and this all mandalorians
being murdered in their Millions once
the planet had been ransacked he then
got his hands on the darksaber and he
attained the rank of moth in 9 ABY he
was almost also put on trial for war
crimes then but he faked his own death
in order to escape persecution he's very
much had his hand in several things and
he's a key component in how the first
order rose up Gideon of course quote
unquote looked after Navarro and their
independence is something that the first
order weaponized throughout the Galaxy
they actually used examples of how
incompetent that the Republic was to get
independent planets to secretly invest
in them in the promise that they could
return Law and Order to the Galaxy
whether this is spelled out in the show
does remain to be seen but I think it's
an important thing to bear in mind when
we're discussing the series as my
thoughts on this episode I'm sure you
can tell I didn't really enjoy it all
that much I think the cameos just kind
of took me out of it I know I'm sure
lizzo's a great person and her fans
definitely love this when it comes to
Star Wars I'm not sure if it feels like
it's fitting for this universe it's the
same with Jack Black and though you know
I love the guy I like little music as
well sometimes I'll have it on the radio
in the background though don't dislike
the video
um I think having them pop up and be
these goofy kind of characters almost
took away from the tone that this
season's been aiming for this has been
very serious and sincere and to just
have this goofy episode though it's fun
you know I'm not sure if it aligned with
my sensibilities it is pretty much just
coming down to that I know I'm looking
on Twitter right now and there's lots of
people who've had a lot of fun with it
but for me yeah I wish the focus was
more on the serious stuff that we got
towards the end online I'm seeing that
lots of people are saying that it's
basically like a Clone Wars episode but
even if it was ranked amongst those I'd
probably put it amongst the bottom the
Clone Wars had some great episodes that
take things seriously and this would be
to me at least one of the more goofy
fellow ones we've got eight episodes a
season to me you've just wasted one so
yeah let's see how they do over the next
two please be good I was saying that
there were some great character
development yeah and it's nice just
watching bow and Mando work together you
can really see how the kind of yin to
each other's Yang and whereas Mando is
filling in bits with the ugnaught Beau
had to come in and kind of settle him
down in other areas they both work
together really well and if people start
to ship them after this episode I can
definitely see why so yeah do I think it
was a great episode no um I think it was
probably the worst one in the season so
far but saying that we've had a really
solid season and yeah let's see what
they do over the next two weeks and how
this leaves the series I think so far
season 2 is still sitting pretty high up
as my favorite of the Star Wars shows
but let me know below exactly what you
think also I just want to give a huge
apology to everyone who was getting into
our bad batch breakdowns I really wish I
had the hours to cover absolutely
everything but unfortunately when things
get too full on it's difficult to
organize things around it with bad
battery man they're releasing at the
same time on the same day it's really
tough doing two jobs at once and bad
batch was unfortunately occasionally of
this when it came to our schedule I will
say that ryanairy did some brilliant
breakdowns on it as well so if you want
to watch some good ones then definitely
head over to his channel and dislike it
got you a son of a I got you in
there and you shut the up Ryan
Airy obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode as well so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in a competition right now giving
away the Superman 4K box set to 3
subscribers on the 15th of April and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode if you pick the comments at
random on the 15th then the winners of
the last one are on the screen right now
so that's you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want someone
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of one of the trailers
released this week there's been a ton of
them so yeah one of them will be on
screen right now and it's been selected
by YouTube as being perfect for you so
yeah definitely head over there right
after this I'll see you next time you
take care yourself peace